The stuffing's my favorite part.
Oh, well I mean it's just a pile
of little pieces of bread,
densely packed together.
What's not to love?
The way you describe shit
is so beautiful.
Thanks.
Okay, so are you ready to show
and tell bay-bay?
Oh yeah ...
Small Business Saturday!
We are like really doing it up
this year.
It is so important to support
local businesses.
So as I was browsing the shops
on Le Canal de Gowanus ...
the Gowanus Canal-
Mm-hmm (affirmative).
I stopped into a local
pottery shop
and got this piece
to support the local artisans.
I guess it's a mug.
You could use it for a variety
of snakes.
Yeah, I'd put my penis in this
if I was a boy.
Look, I'm nosing it.
Okay, you ready for this?
Yup.
I didn't go to Lowe's ...
I didn't go to Home Depot ...
I didn't go
to Hardware Town USA.
I went to my local Dev's
Hardware Store and I got ...
this hose,
because one day I'm going to be
one of those fancy people
that has that wide selection
of dope plant life
on my fire escape,
and when I am,
I'm going to use this hose
to keep those bad boys alive.
Genius ... inspiring ...
and good for the world.
Thank you.
Okay, this auto shop near me
also makes neon signs
for other shops. Check this out.
Oh my gosh.
One, it creates
the perfect ambiance.
Great font.
Two, it's a refreshing spin
on a sad lamp.
Great vibe.
And three, it's
a friendly suggestion.
Great directive.
Thank you.
You did good.
We are really participating
in our community.
Oh, totally.
And you know what, all this
small business shopping ...
we earned Cyber Monday.
Oh, I cannot wait to just
go like this. Boop.
God, I miss Amazon.
Just scrolling,
you know.
It brings my heart rate down.
How much do you think this hose
is if I bought it on Amazon?
It's not like
a local-made hose.
That's right, and it's like
I'm buying something local,
and yet it was made somewhere
else. You know what I mean?